[Music]
hey what's up guys my name is Jenna I am
in Germany right now and is extremely
bright out here and also very hot but
welcome back to another vlog today I
thought we'd talk about what programming
language you should learn first it's a
question that I tend to get pretty often
from people who are trying to get into
programming and are not sure what they
should do in the very beginning I did
make a vlog about a year ago about just
in general how to actually learn
programming definitely check that out up
in the top right corner if you haven't
already but this is just going to be
more about like what I think should be
your first language because it's all
great to talk about how to actually like
the concepts behind learning programming
what I think is the best thing to do in
terms of how to learn programming but
what is step one like which language
should you pick and which language
should you start with what should you
actually do so first of all I just want
to mention that this is gonna be a
complete like as all as pretty much all
my videos this is just my opinion it's
just a complete opinion piece if you
will it's not any kind of fact it's not
backed by anything kind of my experience
I'm just talking about my thoughts
really so don't like don't don't think
that this is definitely the right choice
for you and that this is like some kind
of like objective fact it's just what I
think and really I think that it doesn't
matter so I know that a lot of you
probably annoyed because I'm not giving
a straight answer but it's kind of I
guess that is the answer doesn't really
matter what programming language you
start with because programming languages
are not in the big picture of things
it's not really what your goal is to
learn like when I set out to learn
programming
I don't really set out to learn a
programming language because the
programming language is just the tool
that you use to program a computer right
computers are these complex things that
do many many different things and a
programming language is just something
you can use to actually tell the
computer what to do now there are a lot
of programming languages out there
and the one that is kind of I guess fit
for you or fit for the job that you're
working on fifth bit for the project
that you're working on it's going to
depend on that project and also on you
and just the scale of it and just a lot
of your a lot of different things so I
can't just say learn you know C++ or
learn Java that's the best language to
start with because that doesn't make any
sense you can't just you can't just pick
one language and go with it that's not
how it works
picture picture there's kind of like
building a house if you're a builder
building a house would you really be
hung up on which like brand of power
tools you want to use to build a house
that doesn't really matter does it you
what you actually need to know is how to
build the house and then the power tools
that you use I just a tool that you use
to actually construct that house and
furthermore I guess to extend that
analogy if you were building a house you
wouldn't want a screwdriver would you
you would want like power tools and if
you were on the flip side if you were
building something small you wouldn't
necessarily want massive power tools cuz
I could just wreck the whole thing I
mean it might work but it might wreck
the whole thing and it definitely
wouldn't be as easy and as good as if
you just used a little kind of tiny
screwdriver and you'd be fine so that
kind of is the same as what programming
is like and what software engineering is
like you want to pick the best tool for
the job and it's way more important that
you actually realize how computers work
and how to build the thing that you are
building how to build a software that
you're building and how that
architecture kind of all works then
actually to pick a programming language
and say that's it I'm gonna just learn
C++ and that's gonna be it I'm gonna use
C++ for absolutely everything that's not
how it works I mean theoretically you
probably could use C++ for pretty much
everything
so we're bright out here seriously and
it's funny I didn't bring any sunglasses
with me for this like little vlog here
because I was like oh it's cloudy ass
outside it's gonna be fine it's gonna be
like it was raining all morning I'll be
right anyway the point is you can't you
can't get hung up on programming
languages because in your life you won't
be you won't just be programming in C++
you won't just be programming in say
shop or Java probably you could pick an
extremely narrow specialty I guess and
just kind of
lowly be that person who only knows hit
bust lost but knows it really well but
that's both boring and also in the real
world I don't think I've ever met a
software engineer who just knew one
language or even maybe well prefer to
just programming in what in one language
and that's it and said in order to
absolutely everything else that doesn't
exist because as a programmer as a
software engineer you build software and
building software requires various
languages not just one language so if we
kind of get back to I guess the point of
what it is you should learn first I
think that it depends on what you want
to immediately do right now so what is
your goal right now why are you learning
programming I do you just want to be
able to tell computers what to do and
build software and build like GUI tools
to process data or whatever are you
trying to make it game are you trying to
build web applications or websites what
is it right now that you wanted to
straight away the first thing you want
to do if the answer is a game that's I
guess mildly complicated because you
could build a game in literally any
language because the game is whatever
you define a game to be I mean a game is
just an interactive application with
maybe some kind of goal right that's
what a game really is so you can really
just build that I mean you don't even
need a computer to build at all right
you could build a game just with like a
board game or something like that a game
is really really you know loosely
defined so it's so I mean if you want to
build a game you could really use any
language but suppose you wanted to like
build a website or something well maybe
you should learn JavaScript right if you
want to build I Oh s app specifically
maybe learn Swift if you want to build
Android applications specifically maybe
learn Java if you know build if you want
to get into a triple a game studio and
build game engines then well maybe learn
C++ right it doesn't really matter what
language you pick first because you
definitely won't be stuck with that
language for life unless you choose to
I'm not sure you wouldn't you won't be a
successful software engineer if you only
know one language it doesn't exist so
get that idea out of your head if you if
that's in your head but the the the
moral of the story is that don't get
hung up on this pick a language that is
kind of I guess something that you want
to do now so again if you're kind of if
you want to eventually get into Triple A
games or whatever
whatever it is that you want to do but
right now you just want to build a
website quickly or you think that maybe
it'll be easy to build a website then
learn JavaScript I'll learn like I don't
know PHP what if one of the kids using
these days to build websites probably
like nodejs or something so javascript
again like just learn one of those
things because really the idea is is
actually programming actually building
things using actually building software
and that you can kind of do in any
language so pick something stick with it
and then slowly as time goes on you'll
naturally start to add other languages I
need to leave right now because I'm
melting out here hope you guys enjoyed
this video let me know what your
thoughts are in the comment section
below
regards to kind of what you think a good
good advice would be for a beginner
who's asking what programming language
to learn I mean this that's just my
advice it doesn't really matter
I learned Java first because I wanted to
kind of build really small kind of
applications or games that were like
kind of pixel based and just people were
using Java at the time for that kind of
thing and there was a lot of resources
available but then as soon as I kind of
got into game engines which is very
quickly actually I immediately switched
to C++ and picked that up it was really
hard at the beginning but I still kind
of switched to it and picked that up
because I knew that that would be the
future right for me because I knew that
if I wanted to build game engines I need
to use whatever everyone in the world is
using to build game engines which is say
plus plus and of course now I work at EA
on core technology in the Frostbite
division building game engines in C++
right so there you go that being said
yeah leave your comments in the comment
section below
I forgot this video homey an Instagram
is around Ocampo slash the channel I'll
be kind of documenting all my travels
and stuff I'm in Germany for about four
weeks I'll be traveling around Europe in
general so definitely check out my
Instagram because there'll be tons of
sweet content there and you can stay up
to date that way let me know let me know
other thoughts for vlogs and questions
that you want to answer it because since
I am on the road I'm probably not gonna
sit down and make any formal like C++
series videos or up until very videos
like that because it's gonna be hard for
me to actually sit down with a laptop
and record stuff but kind of
just quick vlogs here and they are
really fun and also are kind of part of
my travels anyway so drop some comments
below us what you want to see and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]